hey guys I'm around right so today I'm
going to be checking out the trailer for
Kung Fu Panda 3 I really like Kung Fu
Panda 1
I didn't finish part 2 I started
watching it with my ex-girlfriend but
now she's my ex so I haven't continued
its ends because it just reminds me of
her but actually now it doesn't really
make me think of her just doing that for
comedy purposes at the beginning of this
video anyway let's watch this trailer a
kung fu master is prepared to train hard
fast
[Music]
we'll be ready for anything
perfect really no again but next January
nothing can prepare him for his greatest
challenge yet
who are you I'm Lee Sam I'm looking for
my son who is everybody Cranston
yes many years ago I lost my father I'm
very sorry
thank you well good luck to you
you too hope you find your son and I
hope you find your father
renew
[Music]
rebel wolf JK Simmons
it's one hell of a cast their wrath
about I have a concern
it's a January release as we know
January tends to be the month when
Hollywood takes a big [ __ ] on cinema I'm
a little concerned about that but you
know what I'm really looking forward to
out of everything I got from that
trailer Bryan Cranston is kung-fu pandas
daddy you're like Bryan Cranston to me
is one of the best actors out there and
he has such a commanding voice and it's
cool to see him in an animated movie you
know I ever it was gonna be a good voice
actor is gonna be Bryan Cranston I mean
so far the trailer doesn't really offer
something that looks totally fresh and
totally different I feel like it's been
a little bit like watered out because of
like the show and stuff so I think this
could be good it's an interesting
scenario but something's it's barely any
footage I know but it still feels like a
little straight-to-dvd to me you know I
didn't finish Kung Fu Panda 2 but I
don't really remember enjoying it as
much when I was like halfway through it
and I remember a lot of people being a
little disappointed by him I mean
majority liked it but there was still a
quite a large amount of people that
didn't like it and this has been like
five years or something so I'm hoping
that they put a lot of extra attention
and care into the script this time but
they have moments like that scenes like
that where it's Jack Black and Bryan
Cranston like interacting with each
other like that PO I think is the guy
thing that was funny to me like that but
just how stupid they both are what a
great time to release this trailer it's
Father's Day clever marketing people
clever marketing I just want to point
that out anyway guys thanks for tuning
into the real rejects if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
where if we get enough followers we can
get private placements meaning less work
for me no benefit for you
cuz Jatin lor do Milic ziering ski hey
I'm a graphic designer
if you want to see what I've made or
want something just right okay um yeah I
want a design of the real rejects I want
it to be with my face over a black / I
want it to be my face over Tyrone
Magnus's body but with my penis sizes
it's way bigger than Tyrone's but make
it black still I want it to look like
it's you know one body if you could do
that that would be a great design and
then you will earn the shoutouts to
genting Lord ooh get a different name